bonjour linda asa war merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors on
l'a dit un nouvelle médiation judiciaire
dans cette affaire qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous alors pour nous
c'est enfin pour les victimes c'est un
peu le retour mon retour en arrière on a
l'impression de repartir à case départ
il ya une audience qui est prévue le 1er
septembre les personnes fallait
personnes toutes celles qui sont
concernées notamment la mairie de paris
et le syndic de copropriété qui sont mis
en cause n'ont pas réussi à trouver un
arrangement est en faveur des victimes
afin de les faire sortir de cette de
cette situation d'abandon et cette
situation de mépris et donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il n'y a rien on sait que le
1er septembre il y aura une audience
mais rien n'est fait encore mais qu'est
ce que vous expliquez que ce soit
justement si l'on vous vous disiez tout
à l'heure on a l'impression de de
repartir du début qu est ce qui vous
semble si l'on on affaire à une
municipalité dans la partie ii de la
voix fin la voie publique et du syndic
de copropriété pour ce qui est de la
partie privée qui aujourd'hui ne
souhaite pas participer on a fait deux
ans qu'on demande de débloquer un accord
cadre et ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on
nous on nous bloque par la création
d'une oie la mise en place d'un
accord-cadre par la création d'une loi
parce que la mairie de paris ne souhaite
pas que sa participation génère derrière
une mise en cause qu'on puisse dire
qu'elle est coupable parce qu'elle a
participé à un accord-cadre en sachant
que je tiens quand même à a précisé que
les victimes aujourd'hui se retrouve
dans cette situation
suit un défaut de voirie donc il ya eu
un manquement au niveau de l'entretien
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu il ya
des décès il ya eu des décès ya des
orphelins
il ya des personnes qui sont handicapés
à vie il ya des personnes qui se sont
retrouvées en dehors de chez eux
du jour au lendemain qui n'ont pas pu
récupérer encore leur logement donc
voila et cela suite à un défaut
d'entretien
qu'est-ce que cet accident a révèle dans
la gestion des logements à paris mais
pas forcément qu'à paris on peut penser
aussi un peu plus loin on se souvient de
l'effondrement de l'immeuble rue
d'aubagne à marseille est-ce que cet
accident traduit un mauvais entretien
des immeubles à paris à marseille en
france de manière générale oui là on ne
le tient rue trévise est l'exemple et
l'exemple concret malheureusement d'une
mauvaise gestion tout à fait d'un défaut
d'entretien qui est clair qui est clair
et qui a causé la mort et qui a qui a
handicapé des des personnes oui oui il
effectivement je confirme aujourd'hui
que vous répond la mairie justement
quand vous les accusez de mal entretenir
ces bâtiments
il ya eu d expertise et d expertise a eu
des rapports qui ont été communiqués aux
parties civiles
donc les experts sont des personnes fin
des expérimentés qui sont capables de
mener une expertise ça fait deux ans et
demi qui a une expertise
donc si les conclusions enfin il ya eu
des conclusions donc voilà il ya des
mises en cause donc des mises en examen
des personnes fin des personnes
la mairie de paris le syndic de
copropriété mis en examen pour
pour défaut d'entretien sur le plan
judiciaire quelles sont les prochaines
étapes à venir dans les semaines dans
les mois à venir
on est en attente alors les victimes
sont vraiment en attente
on ne sait pas on sait que que la fin il
ya eu la demande d'accélérer un peu la
falaise l'instruction et c'est pour que
les pour qu'on ait une date de procès
mais aujourd'hui on est dans le flou on
on revient en arrière avec cette
histoire de médiation ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que certaines victimes ont
par leur avocat pris connaissance que le
médiateur demande et 1000 euros par
victime
aujourd'hui les victimes sont incapables
et n'ont pas les moyens de payer 1000
euros pour une pour le une médiation
donc l'angoissent ajoute l'anxiété aussi
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les victimes sont
exactement sont comme au 12 janvier
c'est à dire abandonner toutes les tous
les frais sont à leur charge
donc nous ce qu'on demandait c'était de
débloquer un accord-cadre cela a été
fait pour plusieurs accidents collectifs
nous ne comprenons absolument pas
pourquoi la mairie de paris le syndic de
copropriété ne valide pas cet accord
quatre comme il a été débloquée pauvres
plusieurs accidents collectifs
merci linda azawad avoir émis avec nous
aujourd'hui sur quatre ans je rappelle
que vous êtes président de l'association
des victimes et rescapés de l'explosion
de la rue de trévise merci beaucoup
merci à vous merci